let's hear from people
people like you in the audience uh we do
calls via discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place to get in touch
with me
let's go first today to vince
from no vince is gone that's too bad
let's go to jason from toronto jason
you're on the air
dave can you hear me i can hear you fine
hey it's a pleasure i've been watching
your show for a while now and i want to
say that
thanks for taking my call and awesome
work on your end what you do is
invaluable so i really appreciate that
my pleasure
uh quick question for you
if trump were still in power
how do you think he'd be handling the
situation in ukraine
um do you think he'd just fold his hands
over the situation and keep the us out
of the situation to kind of
appease his relationship with russia or
how do you how do you think he would
approach it so i think in the this is a
good question in the lead-up to the
invasion trump would have placed heavy
doubt on the intelligence about russia
amassing troops at the border about
russia imminently invading
he would have resisted that
significantly early on and he would have
um so distrust about the intelligence
that pointed in that direction and he
would have said stuff like you know why
would putin do this i don't know i don't
think so putin denied it very strongly
or whatever that would be in the lead-up
once the invasion takes place
i think trump would have similarly early
talked about genius savvy putin just
like he did
but then as everybody around him starts
to say
uh
we've got to help ukraine here this is
this is a war of aggression being waged
by putin putin's clearly the aggressor
we've got to do something i think trump
would have reluctantly been kind of
pulled into helping ukraine in some way
and it would have been similar to when
trump on the day of the riots put out
that statement saying it's time to go
home you know he's like we love you
you're here for the right reasons but
it's time to go home it would have been
a similar sort of like reluctant help of
ukraine that that's the way i imagine it
would have gone
yeah and i i'd appreciate that as well i
think um
nato and and uh the western uh resolve
against this or their position this
would be greatly diminished had trump
still continue to hold the office there
so
i'm kind of glad that uh we have
somebody with a little bit more of a
level head uh taking care of it
um because i think it'd be much
different uh had he still been around so
100 so much thanks a lot for taking my
call i appreciate it thank you so much
appreciate it all right very good to
hear from you